Speaker 1: OK, let's get into some interesting
Twitter posts from this morning. I'm sorry, Reddit
posts Reddit post. You can join the discussion at
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit and more than
33000 of our viewers and listeners are currently
subscribed to Reddit. Few interesting posts that
caught my eye. Homelander posted. Lying about
a vaccination status is way worse than kneeling
for the national anthem. Let's watch all the right
wingers that canceled Colin Kaepernick. Call what
Aaron Rodgers did patriotic. Yeah, I mean, listen,
if you obviously if you believe the pandemic is
real and you believe that vaccines are something
that prevents you statistically from getting
really sick or dying from the virus and all of
that stuff, if you understand reality, you would.
You would have to agree with the statement that
what Aaron Rodgers did claiming to be immunized
when he's not putting teammates at risk, etc. is
obviously far worse than when Colin Kaepernick
kneeled during the national anthem. The problem is
that many of these right wingers and Trumpian live
in an alternate reality where the pandemic isn't
real, or at least it's not serious. And vaccines
are bad. And the worst thing you can do is
something cultural, like kneel during the national
anthem. So you and I agree on this, but the
folks that are living in this alternate reality
don't. There was also an interesting post asking
Who's winning on the vaccine issue politically?
Is it Democrats or is it Republicans? Now, the
people from Reddit who voted in the poll by about
a afford a three to one about 75 25 margin, said
that Democrats are winning on the vaccine issue.
Ideologically, the problem with this is that
the winning would be not dying from the virus.
And unfortunately, there are people across the
political spectrum who are dying from the virus
because in part of the anti-vaccine propaganda
that's being spread. Now that being said,
earlier this week we looked at the numbers. The
cumulative COVID death rate in Trump counties
is now about 50 percent higher than the cumulative
COVID death rate in Biden counties, even within
the Biden counties. It would stand to reason
since the Republicans are the most unvaccinated,
that even within Biden counties, it's more
Republicans dying than Democrats. So it is
becoming Partizan. And if you consider dying from
the virus, losing as increasingly Republicans are,
then that is a way in which Democrats are winning
on the virus, but on vaccination rather. But we
aren't going to get out of this in any serious
way until more people are on board and until
more people are vaccinated. And so unfortunately,
as a country, we've lost a lot, we've lost a lot
and we can point fingers accurately as we
have been doing. But what I want to get to
is the end of the pandemic. And remember, the end
of the pandemic is likely to be COVID becoming
endemic and a certain level of cases and deaths,
much like with flu that are not going to go away
at least for years, at least for a year or so.
Who is really winning feel like we've all lost
a lot over the last year and a half of this
pandemic. One other post from the subreddit
a user is asking for medical advice and says,
Can someone reach out to Joe Rogan and see if
he would consult with me about colonoscopies?
Hi, I'm 23 and highly lactose intolerant. Can
someone ask Joe Rogan if it's too early to start
getting colonoscopies? Is Joe taking appointments?
I'd prefer his expert view on my colon health.
Thanks. So obviously, this is a reference to the
fact that now we've heard that NFL quarterback
Aaron Rodgers took medical advice from Joe Rogan
and enlightened centrist political commentator Tim
Poole took COVID advice from Joe Rogan. Listen,
as I've said before, I don't think there's
anything wrong with talking to people you know
about their experience with the
disease if you were diagnosed with
a form of cancer. It would be totally reasonable
to go talk to a doctor and to get a second opinion
and do all of those things. And if you had a
friend who had had or has that type of cancer,
it's totally reasonable to go and say, Hey, what
were the side effects of the course of treatment
you chose? How did you feel? How did this work?
What was your doctor's recommendation that that
makes perfect sense? But when we start taking
anecdotal advice from non-medical professionals
about things where we have data, things like
ivermectin and others, that's when things sort
of seem to go off the rails. So listen talking to
friends about their experiences with a disease or
medications. Totally reasonable, but the degree
to which Aaron Rodgers seriously said, Well,
I mean, listen, I took advice from Joe Rogan
on what to do starts to get a little weird,
starts to get a little cultish, almost. Join the
discussion at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.